okay hi everybody uh welcome to the last
talk of today so we're gonna have
normally shoot and tell us about the
hunter method and applications to
external communities
if you want
and it tells us that if we have a
function with a small total influence
then it's close to Hunter
informally
foreign
close
you can think of the probability when
you choose X randomly
it holds the Excel
close mean
and
and also Public's best record content is
so
it's also a bad marker
function is a
junta
it depends on J various
so we have them
for example
we have the function FX
equal to x i which depends on one
variable and we have a
f x which is
a little bit
X One Plus
x 2 plus x 3 is greater than zero
majority
functions available
yeah
and this function is
so this is a one theorem so and
once theorem about approximation
and
this approximation they play Central
role in analysis of wooden functions
so on another example another example of
the fountain theorem is the Kindle
Surplus theorem
it says that if the sum
over s at least the
of f of s
well it's smaller than Epsilon
actually
this is for Boolean functions
so if you have a Boolean function that
has all its mass on its low degrees
so if a Boolean function is close to a
low degree function it must be close to
the junta
and what we're going to talk about today
is that
is the appearance of juntas and degrees
in other settings
and in particulars
okay so let's talk about other settings
foreign
about one is
k
the family of all subsets of M
size k
and then
we can ask what are the juntas in this
setting
um
we have to talk about functions
zero one
and this corresponds to families
of sets
about one correspondence
and
we can if we want to find analog of the
educator function
we can take
the family
all sets
that contain I
actually corresponds to the dictator
function
and if you want to take the
family that corresponds to this function
we can take F to B
the families of all sets in and just
okay
intersection with the set one two three
foreign families of sets
and in general the definition is going
to be that f
is a junta
the resistor said J
of size J
so the question
whether a set belongs to f
it depends only
on the intersection of a with j
so here we added the set of one
coordinate the single tone of I if we
wanted to know whether the set belongs
to F we just need to check whether I
belongs to a or not
here that's the same thing with three
elements and
that's the notion of a j funta
full set systems
for families of sets
what about the symmetric group
so here if we have a function f
from the symmetric group to the real
numbers
f
is a j Honda
foreign
is determined
by
Sigma of I
or ing
so
um
for example we can take
the indicator
of all permutations that send I to J
this is
a dictator
this depends only on the value of Sigma
on one coordinate
and
you can also
to find something that depends on sleep
organization
the indicator that
Sigma of one
is one and sigma of two is two and sigma
3 is
and
it turns out that this notion that's
motivated by analysis of Boolean
functions it was actually studied by a
representation theorists because
this notion of a junta it actually can
be described in terms of subgroup or
subgroups of SN
so if we
we have a group action
of SM
in the space on L2 of SN so this is the
space of valid function on SN
and we can let
um
Sigma of Tau b f of a
Sigma inverse of Del that's
full function
and then
F depends
on a
s h j of coordinates
even only if
we take the subgroup
we can take the subwoof of all elements
that
send
J2 itself
if and only if every element in this
subgroup sends F2 itself
foreign
you can Define some notion
and
yeah so for this notion of juntas you
can also take an indicator that Sigma of
one is in a set I this is also a one
Honda that's a good part
and
they both make sense yeah
also talk about the indicator of the
sigma inverse of one is in a set I and
then according to our notion it's not
going to Bear hunda but
with respect to the other action from
the other side
you have
this subgroup of all elements that fix
the subject
and if
depends on the subject or if and only if
for each commutation in this subgroup
when we basically change the values
outside of J we don't change the value
of the function this is what it means
that one which the values
uh of
of the input outside of J it doesn't
change the value of the function
are there any questions about this
okay so that's
and
once we have a this notion of junta
we can already talk about degree
decomposition so we can say
agree
from SN
wow
the minimal d
which yes
the linear combination of the hunters
okay so this is an option for a function
and
also Define a corresponding notion for
representations but maybe
I just stated briefly that you can talk
you can Define the level of
representation
to be a
the minimal
the minimal default which it contains
and
a UJ invariant Vector for deoxysd so
it's the minimal D for which it contains
a different but not a
let's let's not talk about it too much
but it turns out to be a very important
Concept in a representation Theory
so that's what happens in SM
let's talk about dnq
so that we have
dedicators
I get it so again of fq yeah
it's matrices industrial matrices over a
finite field
then we can talk about dictators
you know
the functions of the form fa
is the indicator that's
a of B is equal to U
and
you have this notion
of
Buddha
what does it mean to be a hunter
so f is a
junta
like this
some
Subspace
or fq to the n
for Dimension J
that's that
the value of f on a matrix
depends only
on
the Restriction of a to this Subspace
and then again we can define a function
to be of degree if it's a linear
combination of different
the Boolean Cube you can see that the
characters of the gradient are all the
hunters they all depend on your decoders
foreign
those are the result from
that use this notion of juntas to oh
they don't they didn't call it juntas
but they used
um
but
they used they used this an option of
juntas to get a breakthrough result in
the character theory of
finite simple groups
and
let's
State roughly the results so we have a
class function on the group
[Music]
foreign
so it's a function that's constantly
conducive class yeah
no conjugation
and
this functions
um
equipped
with an orthonormal basis programs
for characters did
these things are called characters but
they're no longer homomorphisms from the
group to the complex numbers they are
homomorphisms from the group to the to
matrices and
that and the process of amorphism from
groups to Medicine
so they've this autonomal basis
and the
basically you can Define the
so these are functions on G you can
uh
so we have this notion of degree that's
defined in terms of what is the minimal
D such they are that such as barely and
in a combination of the juntas
we have this notion of degree for the
character
what the degree of the character is
and
okay yeah
so we said what's the degree for every
function
on the on the group so we said that we
have the notion of the Jack Honda and
then a function is over degree J if it's
a linear combination of Jack Hunters
and actually the gray is a very bad name
because usually for characters 30
degrees the uh is is the value at one
the dimension but
so it's a
so maybe
we know what's the degree of okay this
is just
the minimal default which is a linear
combination of different tasks
and
and unlike the Boolean cuboids
quite easy to determine the values of
the characters on
on elements in other groups it's much
harder to to know the values and even to
estimate these
and
the and what they did they managed to
compute yeah so the S the upper bounded
the qnomes of the characters
for uh for even Q
and then upper bounded and
that's just not enough but the other
bounded kind of G
whenever
I said hey
of all elements in the conjugacy class
is large
it's very similar to the ideas that we
talked about in the last talk
we have
and set
and we want to Upper bound the value of
the character
on this set we can upper bound its qno
and apply tail bonds together the value
is small so
Chi of G
is the inner product
between the set
and the character
foreign
this thing and
upper bound on the Queue Norms of the
characters they correspond
to Autobahn on these values and these
have numerous applications in group
Theory
and then what I'm going to talk today is
about external combinatorics and
the problems that they motivate well we
want to prove up upper bounds in the
queue Norms of arbitrary functions of
degree that are not necessarily the
characters who want to get an arbitrary
function of the greedy and
for a general group and to get something
like the level inequality to show that
all the mass or functions on the group
is concentrated on the high degree so
basically
the Boolean cube is a very special case
a special case of something much more
General that
you can study
[Music]
and yeah so you can think about
certain
and they're gonna make it to know High
multiplicity of it like the bad the
small controversing classes are the ones
when you have one eigenvalue with the
huge Multiplicity
the other ones uh which is more of a
technology then
we get a bound that says that the value
of the character has to be very smart
yeah and basically you have reset the
controversy class and the what the
theorem basically says that if you look
at the indicator of the conjugation
class all of its mass is on the highway
building this is
exactly what everyone says
and these values kind of chicken be sort
of as the full coefficient of the
Congress class so
so what they do is basically upper bound
these values and get the congruency
classes satisfy certain Randomness
properties that are important for
expansion and other problems in
cooperative
thank you
it's the same it's there so these are
the introducible
and
yeah
but in the last session we saw that it's
really quite small and yeah
yeah yeah and yeah so
I mean okay
yeah so if it's
um
it's good and
the last time we said that this purpose
is
I don't know like the identity you won't
be able to say anything for them to be
somewhat large in order
foreign
okay so let's
talk about example metallics
and
songs
the question is how large
can
okay
B
m
or a b and F
equal intersection with n of A and B is
non-empty
one example
of such a family we can take the family
of all sets
especially that I is in a
okay
if you take in times this is going to be
n minus 1 to K minus 1.
and then
there's quite a few says that this is
the largest intersecting family
foreign
thank you
what is the motivation of studying
problems in
or at least for people in theoretical
computer science to study these external
problems in external comedy topics
so there are a few things a few reasons
why I think you should care about them
one thing is that they Inspire the
development of powerful machinery
foreign
leads to connection between
representation Theory and the fear of
boiling functions
there is this paper by and
by Elizabeth
and
and they basically identified that this
notion of a level that appears or degree
that appears in the symmetrical group is
the same notion of a
is the same as the notion of juntas
and it also has specific applications in
theoretical computer science so there is
this result by the North and Safa about
the elements of approximation for vertex
cover
foreign
for the pre-box cube and then
to give a put for it using the noise
operator
requests
for that so
um
they call it for graphs we have two
models of random graphs we have gnm
we can choose
a random graph with n vertices and M
edges
and we also have
GNP
and well we choose every Edge in the
graph to be there independently with
Mobility p
when p
is
when I'm
roughly P times n choose two these
models behave the same
you can do the same thing for the
families of sets and talk about the P
biased Cube
so now we're going to let the cube be
with zero and one
and we'll talk about this P bias
distribution so mu p
and
is the Bernoulli measure where
each x i is one
independently with Mobility p
ath
okay
and then you can say that
function
of the Boolean Cube
yes
intersecting
whenever
foreign
on them
exists a common coordinate for which
they are both one
okay
and then
the people is of the squad assume
says that
if f is intersecting
then
the expectation of f according to the
p-based measure
and that's the P biased analog of the
elderly Squad of field so are there any
questions
yes
so the the this version implies that we
buy this one
in the device case you can get a large
version asymptotic version maybe the
other one but it's not immediate but
it's like
it's like cleaner version so you can
prove I mean gnm and glp they'd be
roughly the same but gen p is much more
nice to work with because of the
independence
so
you have something similar for external
combinatorics when you can talk about P
bias problems and
and you get the same ideas about the
analysis is nicer
we'll give a proof of that essentially
due to a very good
we want to start by defining the noise
so
left X
the Boolean Cube
we let an Epsilon
X be given
by setting
why I
the x i
Mobility Epsilon
and otherwise
choose why
uniformly and independently according to
mutiny
and not uniformly but be biased
me again have this picture of this
Boolean Cube
between the device setting
and for every X we have this
small neighborhood of x
now
the PBS Cube doesn't have
the same Fourier basis as the uniform
Cube but we actually have to come up
with a new basis because the old base is
is not is no longer autonomous
okay
because if you choose a set randomly
according to new pin the number of
elements in it is going to be very close
to P times and it's very concentrated
around its mean so these problems are
roughly the same
so that's the noise operator and
the fully basis for the cube is going to
be again a basis of eigenfunctions for
the noise operator
let's construct this basis
so this basis is going to have the
constant function this is very important
for applications the constant functions
is a part of the basis
and other than that we want to complete
it to an autonomial basis so basically
we can take the dictator X I
make its expectation zero
thank you
and then normalize so it will have
a norm one
that's a basis for zero one
this is called Chi I
will let Chi s be the product
of the ins
you can check the twin p is one half we
get the same basis as earlier
okay now it comes out
the same proof from the phone works
and if you if we Define the operator T
Epsilon of f x to be the expectation
why in this small neighborhood of f of Y
to get that the Epsilon of f
is going to be the sum over f
Epsilon to the s
yes when
is the sum of evidence guys so this is
an orthonormal basis and we can that is
the P by square expansion of s
and it's the Epsilon it has the same
properties of killing the high degrees
so how is it related to the original
problem
this this notion you can actually
extend it
to the case where Epsilon is negative
so how does that work
so we can
look at the probability you can choose X
according to Mu p
and let y
uh be a noisy version of x
and then we can compute
the probability that x i why I is some
vector
KB
and then it's going to be equal to
when a b
is 1 1
is going to be
um
Epsilon p
plus 1 minus Epsilon 3 squared
so we first need x i to be one
and then y i
either be remembered x i with
probability Epsilon or we forget it and
then we have to be lucky and choose it
again with probability p
and
we have this probability of zero zero
this is going to be Epsilon
y minus p
plus 1 minus Epsilon
1 minus P Squared
and
you have the case for a b is either zero
one let's go
but zero
and then
it's going to be
um let's look at one zero so it's going
to be p
and then we have to forget it
I don't forget it we have to be
so it's going to be
p plus 1 minus Epsilon P times 1 minus B
and now you can realize that
this notion actually makes sense
also for negative Epsilon
okay
it makes sense
Epsilon
which is at least minus B
divided by y minus pin
because all of these probabilities are
still going to be you know negative
provided that Epsilon is at least that
number
foreign
Epsilon is equal to minus P divided by 1
minus p
if
and
the probability
one one is zero
case why is
one
is Epsilon three that's all yeah
foreign
the probability of one one is zero this
is the key thing when
yeah so when we choose y according to
nx0 of x
we get that X and Y don't have a common
coordinate that's one so by definition
we get it
the expectation
of x f of Y
zero
foreign
presents a lot of problem
is the inner product between the
external device and X
some
Epsilon to the x times F at s squared
this we can write as
of the empty set Square
plus the sum of the non-empty sets
now we can lower bound each Epsilon to
the S by minus p over one minus p
X
that's it
foreign
and now we can write it as
part of the empty set squared
and times
keep the one minus B
plus the sum of all s
of uh
Plus
B times B and here we have the sum of
all f
and what and how can we
and what can we say about each part so
the full coefficient of the empty set
this is the inner product with the
consonant function
so this is
um
one over one minus B times the
expectation of x square
in this particle
what how can we
um what's the relation between this part
and the expectation of f
olk says that you have four minutes to
give me the answer
okay so it's one when the function takes
values minus one and one but here the
function takes probably zero and one
yeah so
now
and yeah so here f is the indicator yeah
it's it's the indicator also set so this
is a minus P divided by 1 minus B times
the two Norm of f squared
so this is equal to one over one minus B
times the expectation of x squared
minus p over one minus B times the
expectation of f
and when rearranging you get the
if we had the leveled inequality we
could have said that
all of the mass of f is on the high
degrees and then we get something much
better than this P Hill I think like of
b as being small
we if the level is the inequality
um or two then we would get
e to the minus 1 over P so something
exponentially better than the other
squatter theorem
but it turns out the derivative
inequality is not true
in the P bias setting
and instead we have this
full of hyperconductivity for Global
functions and that's what dog will talk
about
that says that in some cases you can
recover this leveled inequality the
other is
functions
called Global functions and these in
some sense the interesting functions
that that uh the non-dictator-like
functions and for this you can get the
level daily quality
and get an exponential Improvement of
their describe
okay so I think let's stop here
any questions
just
so uh so we Define the noisy like
neighborhood uh by sending y to be
exiled probably to Epsilon but then he
took Epsilon to be negative so I was
wondering if there's like a nice
interpretation of the sampling of why
when Epsilon is negative Yeah so
basically there is a unique way to to
couple so if Epsilon is at least minus p
over one minus p and with most one there
is a unique way to couple the P bass
distribution with itself in a way that
you get
the correlation between X and Y I is
Epsilon and that's is it just like
sampling so I guess for the case when
Epsilon is equal exactly equal to
negative p over 1 minus B are you
sampling y from the bias distribution
and then sending all the y i to be zero
whenever x i is equal to one when
exactly and then you have to find the
right probability when X when x i is one
you have to set wire to visual when x i
zero you have to figure out the right
mobility in order to make the
distribution of Y be biased
it's not going to be P because it's
going then it's going to be
yeah
thank you
all questions
operations
group it's like there's a team like it's
like you're moving to the imaginary line
so the steel operators
minus LT uh
it was just something to make a negative
value and everything works yeah you
really formally really but no I mean I'm
trying to make sense of okay properties
it makes sense
it doesn't ever
[Music]
insufficient interpretation in terms of
random box
but at least there are no more questions
let's thank them again
foreign